[SPEAKER_04]: energy system and in this case all across Eurasia from
[SPEAKER_04]: Rome to Hong Kong.
[SPEAKER_04]: But I hope we can do something like this in Africa sometime soon because the same is true.
[SPEAKER_04]: We can have all of the interconnections, all of the physical infrastructure connecting the continent built in the coming years as the great platform for Africa's rapid economic development.
[SPEAKER_04]: As Kevin knows,
[SPEAKER_04]: My view is that Africa can and should aim for economic growth of at least 7% per year.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think it can be even higher than that, up to 10% per year, based on a strategy of strong economic, financial, and monetary integration in Africa, and strong connections of Africa
[SPEAKER_04]: with all of the major parts of the world economy.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think everything we do could be organized around a very high-ambition growth strategy for Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's just a lot of potential headroom for rapid growth by building the core infrastructure
[SPEAKER_04]: and by upgrading and universalizing education at all levels and the science and technology innovation agenda for Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: My very strong view is that not only is this possible, it's a necessity.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa needs to close the income gaps with the high-income world
[SPEAKER_04]: And it needs to do that in a short period of time.
[SPEAKER_04]: By that I mean a quarter century or the next 40 years to very significantly close the income gaps.
[SPEAKER_04]: But for that to be accomplished, Africa needs a very strong pro-investment strategy in which the investments are comprehensive in human capital,
[SPEAKER_04]: in physical infrastructure and of course in all of the main business sectors as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: But my view is that the business investment both domestically generated and foreign direct investment will come on the basis of a strong physical infrastructure and on the basis of rising skills in
[SPEAKER_04]: the young African workforce.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that means a major focus on education both in universalizing secondary school completion, extending university level education to 30 to 40% of the high school finishers, and spurring very consciously
[SPEAKER_04]: an innovation agenda through new science and technology funding and through an industrial policy that is satisfactory.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, how can all of this be accomplished?
[SPEAKER_04]: Because it sounds like a wish list, not necessarily a policy agenda.
[SPEAKER_04]: And my view is that everything depends on the success of Africa-wide integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: could be possible for a few countries in Africa to succeed without Africa-wide success, but not for very many.
[SPEAKER_04]: Much of Africa absolutely will not be able to move forward except in an Africa-wide macroeconomic boom, and that is
[SPEAKER_04]: also for physical reasons, so much of Africa is inland, so many countries are landlocked, so many depend on an Africa-wide physical infrastructure, but also the more basic economic fact that across all economic sectors, from mining to manufacturing to finance and services to the new AI-based economy, scale matters.
[SPEAKER_04]: And Africa as 54 individual member states of the AU will not make it, but Africa as a unified strategy of 1.5 billion people today and 2.5 billion people at mid-century will make it.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that will be a very substantial market.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I believe in the second half of this century, Africa will be one of the great poles of economic growth
[SPEAKER_04]: and will be a centerpiece of the world economy, because Africa will rise to more than 30% of the world population, and I want to see Africa rise to an equivalent proportion of the world economy, which can happen towards the end of this century, but based on an investment-led strategy.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, right now, this is not the way that the world operates, and it's not the way that Africa operates, primarily.
[SPEAKER_04]: because most of African decision-making is still at the national level.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would say the AU level is aspirational but not as operational as it needs to be.
[SPEAKER_04]: Cross-border investments, say on large projects like Grand Inga and many others, don't really work effectively.
[SPEAKER_04]: Countries invest one by one, usually with limited means,
[SPEAKER_04]: with the very narrow domestic financial markets and with a lot of advice coming from Washington saying, don't borrow, don't be too ambitious, don't get ahead of yourselves, you don't really need electricity, you don't really need all these investments, you need stability, which is an argument I disagree with entirely.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa needs rapid economic development.
[SPEAKER_04]: doesn't need stability and poverty, doesn't need slow growth.
[SPEAKER_04]: It needs a high growth agenda backed by an adequate financing structure.
[SPEAKER_04]: So Kevin, of course, and colleagues, that raises many practical questions.
[SPEAKER_04]: But finance stands at the center of those questions.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's easy to say,
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, Professor Sachs, we need more investment, but we can't even borrow what we have right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: We're in debt crisis and so forth.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think all of that actually needs to be rethought.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't have time to elaborate all of my ideas, but my basic thought is that if we understood Africa to be a high growth economy, then everything that looks risky today
[SPEAKER_04]: would not look so risky in the context of a rapid growth trajectory.
[SPEAKER_04]: If Africa's growing at 7% per year, it's doubling every 10 years.
[SPEAKER_04]: If it's growing at 10% per year, it's doubling every seven years.
[SPEAKER_04]: And what looks like a high debt-to-GDP ratio today, in 50 years, we'll see very, very small, because the denominator
[SPEAKER_04]: the GDP will have grown so markedly over that period.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think the IMF gets this wrong.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I think that the credit rating agencies also get this wrong.
[SPEAKER_04]: And because of that, Africa is advised don't borrow or can't access adequate capital.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this becomes a kind of self-fulfilling prophecy of high cost of capital, low borrowing, low growth,
[SPEAKER_04]: and therefore perception of high risks.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I believe we need to turn this around to understand the high growth potential, therefore the much lower risks, therefore the access to low-cost, long-term financing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, there are many, many things to say about how to make such financing.
[SPEAKER_04]: Some of it is really domestic resource mobilization in budgets over a period of 10 or 20 or 30 years.
[SPEAKER_04]: For example, I believe that the way to finance education today is to say that those young children who will get a public finance education will pay a payroll tax 20 years from now when they're in the labor market and a modest payroll tax of 10% of their earnings
[SPEAKER_04]: would pay for their education today.
[SPEAKER_04]: So essentially you would finance universal education, not out of the current budget, but out of future payroll taxes.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's just one example.
[SPEAKER_04]: And I think that there are many ways to mobilize more financing within Africa's own capital markets, but not one country at a time, but through regional integration of the capital market,
[SPEAKER_04]: as well as to have long-term, external finance based on rapid growth scenarios and a specific plan of action on building out the infrastructure and building out the human capital of Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I believe that we can design a high growth trajectory with what looks like quite high borrowing
[SPEAKER_04]: both domestically and abroad for financing that high investment rate, which I'd like to see at around 40% of GDP, but that all of that makes sense when you realize that the resulting economic growth is going to be prolonged and rapid, because then what looks like excessive debt burdens
[SPEAKER_04]: become actually quite modest when looked at the long-term perspective.
[SPEAKER_04]: One reason why the IMF gets this wrong is that its own debt sustainability framework takes a short-term horizon, usually five to 10 years.
[SPEAKER_04]: It asks, what will the debt-GDP ratio be in five years or what will it be in 10 years?
[SPEAKER_04]: But that's the wrong question.
[SPEAKER_04]: The question should be, what will it be in 30 years or 50 years?
[SPEAKER_04]: and how to find the long-term financing to accomplish that.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, in terms of the continental scale resource mobilization, let me just make a few quick points.
[SPEAKER_04]: First, I do believe that there can be tax reform throughout the continent that raises the revenues of government and the share of GDP over time and that this would be advisable.
[SPEAKER_04]: Second, I believe that if the mining contracts are done properly and done in a consistent continental scale, Africa could reap many percentage points of GDP in actually collecting royalties and income taxation from international capital at much more effective collection rates.
[SPEAKER_04]: Of course, this is a matter of corruption, it's a matter of leakage, it's a matter of poorly designed mining contracts, but Africa essentially gives away so many of its crucial mineral resources right now because that's been the game of Europe and the United States, and there are too many companies operating in Africa with the Cayman Island post office box address
[SPEAKER_04]: or some other tax haven post office box address, none of those should exist because Africa needs these revenues.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are Africa's own mineral resources.
[SPEAKER_04]: I do believe that the lending could be made much safer with financial and monetary integration in Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa should aim for a unified currency, maybe over a period of 10 to 15 years.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's time for this.
[SPEAKER_04]: is working, it is the right model.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa should have an African currency.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa should not have its reserves held in France or any other foreign country.
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa needs its monetary independence, but it also needs its monetary integration.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so many crises in Africa have come because of liquidity crises, and these liquidity crises would be
[SPEAKER_04]: avoided entirely with monetary integration and with effectively a functioning African central bank that could address what otherwise turned into uncontrolled tax.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this, I think, is why monetary integration should be part of this strategy.
[SPEAKER_04]: The last point I'd like to mention quickly, Kevin, is that in a multipolar world, Africa has many partners.
And it shouldn't be told which partners those are by any of these individual places.
[SPEAKER_04]: Neither the United States nor Europe should put sanctions on dealing with Russia or Iran or China or any other place.
[SPEAKER_04]: This system of unilateral sanctions that the United States and the EU and UK have imposed is illegal and unacceptable.
[SPEAKER_04]: The only sanctions that are truly sanctionable at the international level are those that are approved by the UN Security Council.
[SPEAKER_04]: No country, not the United States or anybody else, should say to an African country, you can't trade with China, you can't trade with Iran, you can't trade with Russia or with anybody else.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think this is very hard one country at a time in Africa, but the African Union has a policy
[SPEAKER_04]: should reject unilateral sanctions for any of the member states and use its diplomacy at the continental scale to reject such policies.
[SPEAKER_04]: And then finally, Africa needs open trade and finance, as I say, from all of these partners, not only from traditional partners, but from new partners.
[SPEAKER_04]: China is the lead trade partner for much of Africa already.
[SPEAKER_04]: I don't have the count of how many countries that's true, but I would suspect that it is a substantial part of the continent already.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a big change of direction.
[SPEAKER_04]: More generally, the rise of Asia means that India will play a larger role in Africa's trade.
[SPEAKER_04]: China will play a larger role in Africa's trade.
[SPEAKER_04]: The Gulf region should play a larger role in trade and investment in Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've never understood why the Gulf countries promised Mr. Trump $2 trillion of investment in the United States when the returns on that investment in Africa would be considerably higher for both sides.
[SPEAKER_04]: So I think that you can find partners for long-term financing for building out this continental scale program.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll stop there and turn it back over to you, Kevin.
[SPEAKER_04]: But just to say, we need to aim for a high growth scenario.
[SPEAKER_04]: And we need to build the underlying continental scale institutions and the physical infrastructure and the human capital to make that happen.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the wonderful volume, Kevin, that you organized for the African Development Bank spells that out.
[SPEAKER_04]: in detail as a very realistic, high-ambition approach.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that's the one that I think Africa certainly should follow and that will be a success.
[SPEAKER_04]: So let me pause there and turn it back over to you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much, Jeff, for that very interesting intervention.
[SPEAKER_02]: So many thanks to you here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you end with a report on key
[SPEAKER_02]: strategic actions for achieving inclusive growth and sustainable development in Africa, which we co-authored with you and many other experts around the world for the African Union Commission that was adopted by the member states as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: So that implementation is continuing.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so Jeff has given us a number of golden nuggets based on experience.
[SPEAKER_02]: One, Africa should think big, think together, act big, and act long time, if I try to summarize.
[SPEAKER_02]: He repeats what Ahuna told us in the morning, and I think Raymond also said it in the morning,
[SPEAKER_02]: If we act singly as individual member countries of Africa, we will not succeed.
[SPEAKER_02]: If we act together in a multi-polar world, we will not only succeed, but shape the future.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it gives us clear long-term investment strategies and where the money can come from.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tax reforms to raise revenues domestically, and we heard from my presentation
[SPEAKER_02]: over 780 billion dollars waiting for us there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mining contracts, he also talks about how to structure that so that we can track more.
This thing is not working.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so that we can get more
[SPEAKER_02]: really is from what we have the most, what I refer to as sitting on gold and begging for resources.
[SPEAKER_02]: But Jeff, I would even go a bit further.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Minerals Critical Minerals Conference hosted by President C.J.
[SPEAKER_02]: Ota just yesterday, I was asking the mining ministers for mining and minerals, why we are actually mining these agreements instead of
[SPEAKER_02]: of Minerals Development Agreements.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because for sustainable development, it doesn't make sense to ship heavy metals thousands of miles away and produce batteries, and by the thought of lithium ion battery minerals, ship them to US, China, produce batteries and bring them back.
[SPEAKER_02]: The logistics costs are heavy, the carbon footprints are heavy,
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's costly for investment, and I would say that it is cheaper to produce in Africa.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you create wealth, you create jobs for youth, you reduce the carbon footprint, you just win-win for social, environmental, and economic gains.
[SPEAKER_02]: But again, because of path dependency, that would change except if African countries make the policies to change it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Franchising, preferred procurement,
[SPEAKER_02]: local content policies.
[SPEAKER_02]: Financial and monetary integration.
[SPEAKER_02]: Again, a broad point that Jeff raises for us.
[SPEAKER_02]: He says Africa needs this.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Africa knows that it needs it.
[SPEAKER_02]: And that is why the African Monetary Institute, I think I mentioned it in my presentation as well, which takes us towards that African Central Bank.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is just for implementation.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if we go out here and resolve as advisors to heads of states and governments, advisors to prime ministers, advisors and central deputies, central bank governors and chief economists to ensure that we encourage our heads of state and decision makers to operationalize this instrument.
[SPEAKER_02]: That will take us a step to the dream that Jeff has for Africa and I hope we all share that dream.
[SPEAKER_02]: He talked about the debt, and I also talked about the Africa financing stability mechanism that will help us to reduce the liquidity challenges that many countries face that often push them over the edge with regard to debt refinancing.
[SPEAKER_02]: He also talked about the freedom of choice.
[SPEAKER_02]: The discussion on whether China is good for Africa or US is good for Africa is irrelevant.
[SPEAKER_02]: What is relevant is what does Africa want and who provides what Africa wants at that moment.
[SPEAKER_02]: So it depends on the continent to have the freedom of choice.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I think it's Amartya Sen who also defines this as the fact that one is not poor when you have the freedom to choose.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the continent should have freedom of choice of trade partners and so on and so forth.
[SPEAKER_02]: And to do that, he referred to economic diplomacy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Economic diplomacy, to be able to pull our efforts together as a united continent, instead of negotiating as individual small countries in terms of economic power.
[SPEAKER_02]: With regard to the multi-polarity factors we discussed in the morning, we'll pull together and have a united Africa-wide economic diplomacy we can use to push
[SPEAKER_02]: our discussion.
[SPEAKER_02]: Open trade with all partners without exception.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to look east, west, north, and south, not to copy, but to learn from the successes and mistakes that have been made so we can have the benefit of being the latecomer in the old development paradigm.
[SPEAKER_02]: But the good thing about the multipolarity
[SPEAKER_02]: that is happening now.
[SPEAKER_02]: We are all together.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we are not latecomers either.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we can learn from that.
[SPEAKER_02]: So Africa-wide agenda, big agendas, large investments, and focusing on the long term.
[SPEAKER_02]: And Jeff, you threw a challenge on debt.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I want to ask you a question as I throw it to the audience to then ask you questions on the excellent points you
[SPEAKER_02]: You seem to suggest that Africa should have the freedom to borrow more, invest more, for the long term, so that we can, as you clearly explained and showed in the models, that over time, being a high growth region, the debt sustainability landscape will not be the same as what we do if we did it in the short term.
[SPEAKER_02]: The question I ask then is,
[SPEAKER_02]: For a finance minister that has four years as a finance minister, that short-term nature of the appointment, how does he or she deal with the political economy of getting the returns of what he has borrowed before the next election?
[SPEAKER_02]: OK.
[SPEAKER_04]: First, just a general basic economic point.
[SPEAKER_04]: We are usually taught in basic economics that if the returns on an investment are higher
[SPEAKER_04]: than the cost of capital.
[SPEAKER_04]: And equivalently, if the net present value of the investment is positive, it should be made.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the investment test.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you look at the investments in infrastructure and in human capital, and try to quantify the returns to those investments using a variety of methods, the evidence is overwhelming.
[SPEAKER_04]: that investing in Africa's development is a high-reference activity.
[SPEAKER_04]: In other words, the return to African investment in a financial sense is perhaps 15 to 20 percent compound return.
[SPEAKER_04]: The return on having a young African child go to school and go all the way to upper secondary, complete upper secondary, and go to
[SPEAKER_04]: some tertiary education is a return of around 20% internal rate of return.
[SPEAKER_04]: And yet the fact is these high return investments are not being made even though the cost of capital is clearly far less than these returns.
[SPEAKER_04]: And the reason is a couple of things that we've mentioned.
[SPEAKER_04]: One is the vision.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's said in the IMF and the World Bank, well, if your debt to GDP ratio rises to 50% of GDP, that's too high.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's not sustainable.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's a perfectly arbitrary number.
[SPEAKER_04]: It has no basis.
[SPEAKER_02]: We seem to be missing your voice, losing your voice.
[SPEAKER_03]: Chiefs are literally, but I support it, for countries that don't have discipline.
[SPEAKER_00]: We've got to borrow the money and we should use it.
[SPEAKER_00]: IT colleagues, please can you check and bring the advice.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know the purpose for which they are borrowing.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we try to round off this session as well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, as we are waiting for Jeff, does anyone have a question that we can collect?
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to save time for Jeff, so that if he does come back, we will take the next two, three minutes to respond to him before we move to the next agenda item.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, please.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_03]: I just want to make a comment on the fact that Africa should grow fast and ensure rapid economic growth.
[SPEAKER_03]: I fully agree with that.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I also want to say that the heart is not just about the speed at which African countries grow, but also the quality of the growth forces.
[SPEAKER_03]: matters a lot.
[SPEAKER_03]: The distributional effect of the growth is, in itself, very important to ensure that that growth is sustainable.
[SPEAKER_03]: More often than not, we have seen this situation where countries within the continent grow, but they don't use, or the key growth drivers have been through extractive sector, extractive mining, oil,
[SPEAKER_03]: And what have you?
[SPEAKER_03]: And many cases, I mean, from oil, from mineral, gold, and other, that tend to degrade the environment more and create very limited jobs in a way, because many of these investments have been after, you know, intensive in nature.
[SPEAKER_03]: So how do we ensure that, yes, we have to grow faster, but the quality of the growth process and distribution matters also?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, thank you very much, Jeff.
[SPEAKER_02]: I understand you are back online.
[SPEAKER_02]: This question is on how do you marry the speed of growth, which you are encouraging, and also the quality of growth in Africa, given that sometimes growth on the continent are commodity driven and not inclusive.
[SPEAKER_02]: So maybe you're adding to the response that you already gave.
[SPEAKER_02]: Over to you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, yeah, yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_04]: Sorry about the line dropping.
[SPEAKER_04]: The power went out briefly in the hotel.
[SPEAKER_04]: I was just going to say that the biggest issue of borrowing actually is short-term liquidity crises.
[SPEAKER_04]: And this brings us just to say two things.
[SPEAKER_04]: One, managing the maturities of debt is crucial.
[SPEAKER_04]: Debt should be long-term because the investments are long-term.
[SPEAKER_04]: And second, that's the case for an African central bank because liquidity crises require active central banks.
[SPEAKER_04]: And when Africa borrows in dollars, the central banking question is, unfortunately, the Federal Reserve, not an African central bank.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so to avoid liquidity crises,
[SPEAKER_04]: requires African central banking that is active.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, let me turn to the question about the quality of growth.
[SPEAKER_04]: The core quality of growth will come through the quality of the skills of Africa's labor force.
[SPEAKER_04]: This is going to be the main determinant in the future.
[SPEAKER_04]: And yes, you can sell minerals, but as the speaker said,
[SPEAKER_04]: That doesn't create jobs.
[SPEAKER_04]: That doesn't create broad-based development, though it could create government revenues that support broad-based development.
[SPEAKER_04]: What creates broad-based development is quality education that turns into business investment and job creation.
[SPEAKER_04]: And there, the point is that, Kevin, when you mentioned, for example, why sell critical minerals instead of
[SPEAKER_04]: being core to the battery supply chain, which is certainly readily within Africa's reach.
[SPEAKER_04]: The most important factor, I would say, for the battery supply chain is not only the strategic decision that that's the way Africa will go, but training a generation of engineers that are going to be making those companies.
[SPEAKER_04]: One of the most impressive things about China's success, by the way, and I spend a lot of time in China, is the young engineers that are making these companies that suddenly become world-leading companies.
[SPEAKER_04]: These are young people, 35, 40 years old, but they are well-trained engineers, both domestically and they've gone abroad.
[SPEAKER_04]: I would like
[SPEAKER_04]: Africa and Chinese universities to be cooperating very actively on building that engineering core for strong entrepreneurship and engineering in the battery sector, for example.
[SPEAKER_04]: We know a lot of CEOs of the leading African, leading Chinese battery manufacturers.
[SPEAKER_04]: They want to invest in Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: You show them a skilled workforce, they'll be there, believe me.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you show them the supply lines, the business environment, and a skilled workforce, they will come.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that, I think, is where the jobs are going to be created, with the skilled workforce.
[SPEAKER_04]: Let me just add that most of the jobs that will be created in the future in any economy will be in the service sector, in education,
[SPEAKER_04]: in healthcare, in teaching, in public administration, in banking, in finance, in logistics.
[SPEAKER_04]: The reason is that in manufacturing, mining, and agriculture sectors, there is going to be an even accelerated automation and an accelerated introduction of robotics across all economies.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so the jobs are going to be in the face-to-face human service
[SPEAKER_04]: economy, but those are going to be skilled jobs based on skilled workforce, engineering, technical training, and that's where I would put a lot of the emphasis in this human capital investment strategy.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much, Jeff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Just one more question, and then we'll move on to the next session.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know we can spend the day with Jeff here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Please, the gentleman on the third row.
[SPEAKER_02]: The mics, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gentleman on the third row.
[SPEAKER_01]: Thank you, Professor Sachs, and thank you, Dr. Roman.
[SPEAKER_01]: I would like to respectfully disagree with Professor, especially relative to the accumulation of debt by most African countries.
[SPEAKER_01]: The issue is that over the years, a lot of African governments have tried to change the way they will go to the market.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's a big problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: And what comes up to fight their way along will be interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we've gone to a number of these countries and we've seen the issues they are going through.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's something that is an issue.
[SPEAKER_01]: Another thing Coline talked about here is the issue of the level of education in Africa.
[SPEAKER_01]: Most of the well educated Africans do not want to stay in Africa.
[SPEAKER_01]: I remember several years back when I went to the U.S. to go to school, my relatives were telling me why I couldn't run away to stay in the U.S.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, I told them that I had a mission to do.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's a difficult proposition that people who stay in Africa in the school system are not human.
[SPEAKER_01]: They are not competing.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean Africa has, I think that we have to look at a revolution around the world.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we go to some of our new president, but I think we have to be frank.
[SPEAKER_01]: Some of these things that people talk about are all theoretical.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we as practitioners, we know what is happening.
[SPEAKER_01]: My brother and I talk about growth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Growth is not sheer in Africa.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, we can't look at growth at 50%.
[SPEAKER_01]: So what is the solution?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the solution is that it has to be carefully looked at.
[SPEAKER_01]: It has to be a .
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if we talk about solution now, it will take the whole time.
[SPEAKER_01]: There are a lot of things that we need to look at.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I don't want to say that our white professor is saying that it has to be done straight from here.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not like I want to say, well, we need to create a central bank.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think that requires a response.
[SPEAKER_01]: My view on this is that you say you need to look at the context and that contexts matter.
[SPEAKER_02]: the context I think that is a very valid point but also need to look at the objectives as well because if you ask the European Union when they were starting all conditions were not perfect and I'm not one who waits for perfection before taking action because if you wait for perfection you wait forever they always say let not excellence be the enemy of the good so if we know the direction we need to go we need to go there in faith
[SPEAKER_02]: and somehow you learn as you go as well, while trying to build in all the evidence that we have as researchers to create the right direction.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jeff, do you want to comment on that as part of your one-minute closing remarks so that we can move on to the next agenda item?
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Very good.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think just in response, Africa needs a strategy and a plan
[SPEAKER_04]: that addresses these multiple issues.
[SPEAKER_04]: Of course, debt sustainability is an issue, and that's why I suggest a strategy based on long-term maturities and many other factors, but not to take as given the current situation, which is a completely inadequate structure.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not advocating to go out and borrow
[SPEAKER_04]: a four-year or five-year euro bond.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the opposite of what I'm recommending.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm recommending an investment strategy that shows long-term growth and borrows at long-term maturities backed by support for liquidity of governance.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that is a way to address the gentleman's concern.
[SPEAKER_04]: Also, young, educated Africans will want to stay in Africa.
[SPEAKER_04]: if they can get a quality education, and if they are part of a rapidly developing and growing society.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that is what we have seen in many places, in China, in India, and I regard Africa as next, as the one that's going to achieve this very rapid growth.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, at the very beginning, Chinese students went abroad and stayed abroad.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now not only do the Chinese students come home, but the Americans go to China because that's where the future is.
[SPEAKER_04]: And so we have a different flow because of the reality that one place is very dynamic and innovative and the other unfortunately is not.
[SPEAKER_04]: So young, educated Africans will want to stay in Africa in a dynamic and growing economy where they can raise their families,
[SPEAKER_04]: and make money and see a bright future.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that is absolutely possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much.
[SPEAKER_02]: On that note, we need to also work on debt productivity, as raised by a colleague here, and long-term cheaper costs, investable resources that can create long-term assets for growth and capital accumulation by the country.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's give a round of applause to Jeff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thank you very much